[Music]
where are you going to go first
[Music]
thank you i love it hi my name is
annabelle bellaga i'm 10 years old i'm
avery and i'm six years old
i'm andrew rosenblum i'm nine years old
the best gift i've ever gotten was my
puppy
probably a trip to legoland my bike i
have a challenge for you i'm going to
give you
one hundred dollars and one hour
to find and buy a gift for your grandma
do you think you can do it yes oh yeah
what do you think your grandparents are
gonna like i'm gonna get my grandma
something that she can use in the
kitchen because she likes toys a lot
and for my grandpa maybe like a picture
frame of me and my siblings or something
for golfing
my plan of action is to buy her a bunch
of small
things several of them that equals up to
a hundred dollars
maybe something disney related what are
some of the gifts you thinking
like a foot massage and
some nice bed pillows do you think you
know where you can find them in the
store
yes all right so let's go
where are you gonna go first all right
who are you gonna look for first
these look really good too hard
this one are you sure that's the size
that's neatest
yes i think that's too big for grandma
okay because you need something that
says
queen perfect size
what types of things are you seeing here
i think a lot of utensils
and books
[Music]
what is her favorite thing the whole
world besides the kids
she does like me
the suitcase says loves travels it's in
pink and the world one has the whole
world
what kind of thermos are you looking for
i'm looking for the one that is
nice and hot make it hot what's
grandma's favorite color
gray this one
has rainbows on it look at this one just
right now what is that
i don't know all different pictures i
can do that that's nice
but now we have to go find the pictures
do you want to do that yes i'll do this
okay so you want to do okay my nana
isn't really good with this thing
oh she's not she likes she likes well
that's a good thing to know
that's why well we have this family tree
one that doesn't dangle
it's a tree and in the back it says
family israel love grows too that's
pretty that one is the same thing but it
doesn't dangle
do you like this one or this one which
one do you like
this one is that grandma's size yeah all
right so go find grandma's side
this one is perfect
that's a great picture i like that one
how many pictures do you have now
all right let's see what it looks like
make it big
i like that hey mommy grandma used to
eat for her thermos too
okay it has all different stuff
so let's put it in i think we have about
20 minutes left
what else are we getting what did you
say we need to get a book
our foot massage what's the total 55.74
here's some paper and a pencil so
you have a hundred dollars right how
much did you just spend 55.75
74. so how much do you have left to
spend
44.26 44.26 so go
okay so that one's 40.
so you just have enough money yeah and
you might even have
like five dollars left over yeah you get
like a polishing closet
nice and clean
that's what you want to get for grandma
that's the big gift yeah
why do you want to get that for grandma
because it's
good for her skin and you could actually
use it for if your feet are tingling
this one looks good it gives it
her smooth skin oh so she can lay her
bed
nicely what are you thinking now cutting
words
i like that one well that's only fifteen
dollars and there's only two left
though okay oh you actually have 28.27
[Music]
all right so how much is the total
eight dollars and twenty-eight cents all
right what are you gonna get for eight
dollars and 28 cents um
four minutes four minutes can i believe
it
nope you gotta spend all of it get less
than a minute annabelle
i don't know what to do i got one what
is that
it's uh um 62 cents
62 cents i think you did it what do you
think
yes good job annabelle you think that we
have
a hundred dollars worth of stuff yes you
think we can go to the register
yes are you ready yes all right let's go
fast fast faster i spent exactly a
hundred dollars in under an hour that's
what i call a mission accomplished
[Music]
yeah i got a holiday gift for you that
is so sweet of you
thank you can i open it
[Music]
hi grandma hi baby you get
my gifts yes i did and i'm gonna
open it and look at them hey
wow what is this
it's a problem you bought me a robe
yes yeah thank you i love it it's warm
good to see you you can open the box
grandma's kitchen meals and memories
served wow i got a cutting board
[Music]
oh how thoughtful of you oh that's
gorgeous that's a is that a family tree
yeah i bought this because you like
family i love
my family
a suitcase yeah because i know you like
traveling
oh these are the best ever i love you
oh thank you pillow
thank you thank you very much i love you
i love you too grandma thanks
bye this is a photo
oh it's like adventure dinner friday
than me and my family and then that's
gonna arrive on the 15th
wow beautiful and i hope you really like
them
i do i do i feel excited i will be
waiting we'll be waiting for that
thank you so much
[Music]
you